it's a daily ritual now
and it's a collective ritual in a town
so traumatized by curvid 19
where over 6 000 people died as the
pandemic struck
forcing hundreds of thousands into
lockdown unable to say goodbye to their
loved ones
the cemetery is a place to come and
mourn and remember together
the graves of the covid dead in bergamo
the worst hit place in lombardy
are often positioned near each other
they're simple and poignant
the final resting place for the old and
the young
coronavirus didn't discriminate in the
lives it took
as with britain there are calls for a
public inquiry into the government's
handling of the disaster
but here they've gone further legal
action has been launched by families of
the dead
armando invenici died in march his wife
monica and their son nicola
want answers they don't want money or
compensation
just an acknowledgement of mistakes
[Music]
bergamo like the rest of italy is out of
lockdown
but the wearing of masks is mandatory
social distancing in bars and
restaurants is strictly observed
temperatures are regularly tested and
alcohol can't be drunk on the streets
after 7 pm
[Music]
towering over bergamo is the old city
a beautiful medieval town once the
westernmost point of the venetian empire
it's slowly returning to normal although
while it may look busy in reality in
summertime the streets would be
absolutely heaving
there are few foreign visitors here this
year
the city and its inhabitants are far
from getting over what happened here
trying to navigate a way forward is the
job of mayor
giorgio gory he imposed the lockdown
now he's overseeing its unlocking i
suppose
all the countries have to accept that
dealing with the covid virus outbreak
doesn't just
end after a few weeks it goes on and on
and on yeah
it i i think that
one part of our difficulty
comes from the insurgency that we have
to face
about this this new enemy because
after six months more or less
we don't know yet exactly what what kind
of
of enemy we have in front of us
we don't know if the virus is changing
we didn't know
if the the the
the viral charge is declining
we don't know if there are permanent
effects
we don't know if it if is
affected by the temperature if in the in
the fall
as happens with with the normal
influence
uh will it will back
and there are so many things that we
don't know yet
um i i in myself
and i it is the same thing that i say to
my citizens
is that we have to be ready to phase
or call coexistence with virus
amid fears of a second wave of the
deadly virus bergamo remains a cautious
and melancholy place
they won't forget what happened here but
they will move on
but at a distance with clean hands and
wearing a mask
stuart ramsey sky news